Batman unites the world's greatest DC  superheroes this fall in Justice League  before the Justice League Batman was a  one-man war on crime he struck fear into  the hearts of Gotham's criminals with  brutal tactics and intimidation the man  brooding under the mask wasn't some  supernatural creature but billionaire  playboy Bruce Wayne orphaned at a young  age and obsessed with preventing a  tragedy like this from ever happening to  someone else  Bruce hardened his body and mind into a  weapon against injustice highly trained  in martial arts stealth strategy and  detective work Batman is one of the most  formidable forces in the DC Universe  Batman first appeared in 1939 and was  part of the Justice League from the very  beginning the bat of Gotham fearless Lee  goes toe to toe with his own rogues and  is ready to stand against evil no matter  how impossible the odds Batman may never  ask you over for afternoon tea but his  dedication to justice makes him both a  leader and a hero